[Music]
our mission in the elho project is to
reduce the dependency of eu and imported
proteins by exploiting the alga and the
plant-based residual biomass and waste
to the circular bioeconomy these will be
then converted into safe sustainable and
healthy alternative proteins for field
and food additives
[Music]
i'm halfway through my phd and have two
more years to finish this exciting
journey
the covert restrictions did for some
challenges because of the restrictions
in travel and communication between the
partners and institutions
[Music]
for me personally europe has encouraged
me to lead
by giving me the support to choose how i
want to pursue my dream in food science
it has given me the liberty and
opportunity to be innovative be creative
and to explore
the fact that the most recent part
breaking discoveries the gene editing or
mrna vaccines are all being led by women
scientists is highly uplifting we are at
the precipice of unprecedented advances
in science and technology and i wish all
the young aspiring scientists the best
of luck be bold be brave and be curious
[Applause]
[Music]
you